In 2010, the Miami Heat tried to build a dream team...
...around Lebron James and two other stars.
And Lebron promised that they would win some championships...
...but they struggled to even win close games in the regular season.
So the next year,...
...instead of picking up another star, they added Shane Battier.
And Shane told me people were not impressed.
...and people looked at my limitations...
...and say, "Oh, Battier is not athletic..."
"...and he doesn't run pick-and-roll..."
"...and he can't really dribble."
But here's the weird thing:
When Shane was on the court,...
...every one of his teams were statistically more likely to win.
He ended up becoming a key contributor...
...to the Heat's back-to-back championships.
So, I asked Michael Lewis, the author of "Moneyball" to explain it.
So, he wasn't athletic enough to stop Kobe Bryant,...
...but he was smart enough and kind of canny enough...
...to force Kobe Bryant to places on the floor...
...where he was a less efficient shooter.
So, he was doing all these things...
...that are very valuable that no star would bother to do.
Lots of stars means lots of egos.
And lots of egos means infighting.
In a team, you can actually have too much talent.
Look at the evidence from soccer.
Teams with a mix of stars and role players...
...actually win more games in World Cup qualifying matches.
We see the same pattern in NBA basketball.
You're actually better off with two stars on the court than four.